let's say that I've got a triangle and
this is this is the side has length B
which is equal to 12 12 units or
whatever whatever units of measurement
we're using let's say that this side
right over here this side right over
here has length C and that happens to be
equal to 9 and that we want to figure
out we want to figure out the length we
want to figure out the length of this
side and this side has length a so we
need to figure out what a is going to be
equal to now we won't be able to figure
this out unless we also know the angle
here because these things could be you
could bring the side this the blue side
and the green side close together then a
would be small but if this angle was
larger than a would be larger so we need
to know what this angle is as well so
let's say that we know that this angle
which we will call theta is equal to 87
degrees so how can we figure out a and I
encourage you to pause this and try this
on your own well lucky for us we have
the law of cosines which gives us a way
for determining a third side if we know
two of the sides and the angle between
them the law of cosines tells us that a
squared is going to be equal to B
squared plus C squared now if we were
dealing with a pure right triangle if
this was 90 degrees then a would be the
hypotenuse and we would be done this
would be the Pythagorean theorem but the
law of cosines gives us an adjustment to
the Pythagorean theorem so that we can
do this for any arbitrary angle so the
law of cosines tells us going to be a
squared is going to be B squared plus C
squared minus 2 times BC 2 times B C
times the cosine times the cosine of
theta times the cosine of theta and this
theta is the angle that is that opens up
to the side that we care about so we can
use theta because we're looking for a if
they gave us another angle right over
here that's not the angle that we would
use we care about the angle that opens
up into the side that we are going to
four so now let's solve for a because we
know what BC and theta actually are so a
squared a squared is going to be equal
to B squared so it's going to be equal
to 144 plus C squared which is 81 so
plus 81 minus 2 times B times C so
that's minus 2 I'll just write it out
minus 2 times 12 times 9 times 9 times
the cosine cosine of 87 degrees cosine
of 87 degrees and this is going to be
equal to this is going to be equal to
let's see this is 225 225 minus let's
see 12 times 9 is 108 108 times 2 is 216
minus 216 times the cosine of 87 degrees
87 degrees now let's get our calculator
out in order to approximate this and
remember this is a squared actually
before I get my calculator out let's
just solve for a so a is just going to
be the square root of this so a is going
to be equal to the square root of all of
this business which I can just copy and
paste it's going to be equal to the
square root of that so let me copy and
paste it so a is going to be equal to
the square root of that which we can now
use the calculator to figure out so let
me increase this radical a little bit so
that we make sure we're taking the
square root of this whole thing so let
me get my calculator out so I want to
find the square root of 220 actually
before I do that let me just make sure
I'm in degree mode and I am in degree
mode because we're obviously finding the
we're evaluating a trig function in
degrees here so that's fine so let me
exit so it's going to be 225 minus 216
times cosine cosine of 87 degrees not 88
degrees 87 degrees and we deserve a drum
roll now this is going to be fourteen
point six one or is it fourteen point
six one eight if say we wanted to round
to the nearest
hands just to get an approximation it
would be approximately fourteen point
six so a is approximately equal to
fourteen point six however whatever
units were using long